but the point the point is like sleeping
with multiple people does impact your
ability to pair bond yeah I didn't sleep
with much people I know but it doesn't I
know I'm not
said more than one oh okay yeah like
many yeah because even even when you no
no I'm not I'm not making a judgment on
what is a lot that's not my point okay
is the more people that you sleep with
the harder it's going to be for a guy to
get married to you and that's not a fun
truth I don't think that because I think
as women like we're forced to make
decisions a lot sooner than men and
you're given a lot of attention from a
young age especially if you're like a
very pretty girl like at like 15 you
have guys hitting on you all the time
and I think girls have to make decisions
quick yes but I I think it's dishonest
to say there's no consequences to like
sleep in with multiple people because
there are and at least as women like we
can have this conversation and like be
honest to the next generation of women